better ingredients the better Pizza Papa
John's the quantum filled the physics of
manifestation and synchroniticity where
you're out in the three-dimensional
world into the quantum field of nobody
no thing nowhere pineal gland is the
antenna to the divine
Papa John's Pizza is one of the most
successful franchises of all time with
over 5 000 locations more than two
billion dollars a year in revenue and an
eccentric CEO who came from nothing Papa
John although before we go into that I
gotta say that if there's anything I've
learned about running a business it's
that working is not the same as being
productive so many people spend half of
their work day doing things that a
software could just do for them if you
want to help restructure your business
but you don't know where to start just
remember these three numbers from our
sponsor netsuite it's thirty six
thousand twenty five and one thirty six
thousand because over 36 000 companies
have already upgraded to netsuite and
stopped wasting time on things like
manual data entry and sifting through
scattered data 25 because netsuite has
spent 25 years helping businesses close
their books in days and one because
netsui is an all-in-one solution that
allows you to manage all of your kpis or
key performance indicators with one
efficient system if your business is
scaling netsuite will make sure that
your busy work does not scale with it
have a full picture of your business and
make Better Business decisions faster
with netsuite right now download
netsuite's popular kpis checklist
absolutely free at netsuite.com iced
that's netsuite.com iced iced to get
your own kpi checklist for absolutely
free again netsuite.com iced or the link
is down below in the description to get
started and now let's get back to the
podcast thank you so much for allowing
us to come here this is my first time by
the way ever in Kentucky and this
property is amazing it is jaw-dropping
that's pretty special knowing that
you're in real estate you put 150
million in assets and you like my
property so thank you for that love it I
mean just it it because we don't get
this in both Las Vegas or Los Angeles
the lot size is if you get an acre and
either one is like tremendous but how
big is this this is 26 Acres most people
buy it in a state and they build houses
around the estate because the states are
so big yeah what I did is I bought three
or four houses torn down in the building
in the state so um the estate's name is
valomita it's Greek for if it is to be
it's up to me it's accountability you
know I think when the framers frame the
Constitution and set out the principles
of our great nation I think
um independent critical judgment
Liberties self-accountability
self-respect I think those were the
backbone of the individual has to take
care of the individual the state doesn't
take care of the individuals so Alameda
if it is to be it's up to me do you ever
leave the property it seems like
everything you need is is here you have
like a golf course in the middle The
Fountains as we were walking in I mean
it's such a presentation when you drive
by it and just see the front of the
property it's very like it yeah you know
if I had two billion dollars all I would
do is build stuff all day long because I
just love to build I mean I get I just
love creating spaces you know this
little clubhouse here is fun yeah design
science said the imagination is so much
more powerful than the intellect got to
run everything on intelligence and the
the imagination
um creativity
uh intimacy the bonds we have the
energies the vibrations the frequencies
um that's you know as Einstein said the
the field governs particles you know
particles and molecules don't govern the
field so I think creativity and
independent critical judgment
um creating stuff is really a key to
being happy whether you're knitting or
you're an orthodontist and you're
straightened teeth or you're an engineer
and you're Building Homes I think the
creative aspect of the mind is Einstein
said the imagination is most important
so where as I was building you know a
half a restaurant or a restaurant a day
and we had 120 000 employees we're doing
4B in a year we're making 200 million a
year in ebitda
um that was a lot of creativity to do
that out of the broom closet
um so what I do is I keep myself busy
since I don't have a job just building
stuff so you know I've got some work I'm
doing out in Utah with some property
I've got some remodels in Naples Florida
you saw what's going on here at Alameda
so we always have work in progress to
keep the Mind active so how does that
require creativity to be building one
restaurant per day for me I just see
that I'm like okay you have to be highly
analytical you have to think very
logically to do something like that I
feel like it to me I don't see the
creativity in it but how does that
require creativeness well if it was
sheer analytics and it was sheer cause
and effect
um and then remember there's 43 000
independent pizzerias 55 is a big chains
Caesar Domino's Papa John's and Pizza
Hut five or ten percents frozen pizza
and the other 35 40 is the independence
the one store Mom and Pops every single
independent Pizzeria
wants to be Papa John's so how we were
fortunate enough and lucky enough
and
um fortuitous enough to be the one out
of the 43 000 Independents that was able
to create 5 000 stores I would argue
just on sheer common sense that you know
the creativity of
where you locate the store and where you
put the signs and how do you get this
permitted and for example you know right
turns when you deliver pizzas are 40
faster than left turns so when you
locate a store you always want to be
doing right turns out of the store it's
40 faster I think UPS was the one that
uh
did that with right hand turns which I
find really interesting yeah I don't
know I don't know who came up with that
yeah but yeah the every store uh is an
individual store in fact that's one
thing that we
did completely different than the chains
was the mindset but what we did at Papa
John's is we looked at ourselves as the
largest independent Pizzeria in the in
the world in the country we didn't look
at it at 5 000 stores doing four billion
a year we looked at it one store five
thousand times so if that small operator
in that small town or that one or two
store manager and the system wasn't
making money then the overall health of
the Enterprise couldn't be good and that
was a completely different mindset to
approach this from the element of one
store five thousand times have you
always been creative and liked building
things even as a kid like where did that
start I think it started at my
grandfather's he had a farm we did a lot
of lawn work
um
shrubs trees planting flowers but I can
remember my roommate Brian Tennis and
gray Cabell we had a triple which was
twice as big with one less person you
know three people they were golf
um uh
academic scholarship golf guys and so
they were always gone so I got the
triple to myself but I remember we redid
that room I took all the bunks up to
about six inches to the ceiling so we
had the whole space and we had a little
bit of a bar and you know we had a beer
tab in there and yeah wine glasses thing
from the ceiling and the couch so we had
our own nightclub on the top of
Studebaker dorm in 1982-83 so we've
always liked creating stuff and creating
spaces so yeah I think that's kind of my
nature but you were also an entrepreneur
growing up
um what were some of the first
businesses that you started was that
also inspired by uh your grandfather my
grandfather always put us to work with
odd chores and painting gutters and
cutting grass we had that business pump
gas on um on the Ohio River for a dollar
fifty an hour back in the 70s I didn't
know I was an entrepreneur all along and
I had that Knack but I didn't know I had
it until I got thrown in the broom
closet or not the Brew closet in the bar
I didn't I didn't really know until Dad
said hey you got to fix this bar
that I had any kind of business sense or
entrepreneurs since I mean that was
um Labor Day weekend of 83 I guess had
been September
and we were 64 000 in bankruptcy and um
you know within a week I felt like I
could fix that business so if I get the
storyline correct your father was
running a bar it got like you said 60 or
some thousand dollars in debt at what
point did you know that you could turn
that business around and make it
profitable bring it out of debt was
there some aha moment this is really odd
because remember this is 83 Psalm 21 uh
first Papa John's is 84. I'm 22. dad
thought he was 10 15 grand in a whole So
within two or three weeks I said Dad
it's not 10 or 15 it's more like 20 or
25 ended up being 64 000. and he goes
well you know he was the youngest City
judge in the state of Indiana's history
um Prosecuting an attorney for eight
years attorney a lawyer for what 25 30
years in Jeffersonville so he uh had a
good reputation in the community and he
was getting ready to take all these
people around him that were friends down
with him and he said well just limit the
losses and
um just do what you can do
um and I said no dad I think I could fix
this now why I thought
um at 21 never running a business that
two weeks three weeks in that I could
pay off twenty five thousand dollars and
past debts I don't know fast forward to
the broom closet we um we had a lot of
success in the room closet we were doing
over 3000 a week and all of a sudden
um we had to build a store to hold the
volume so we opened a store Jason to mix
Lounge
and the volume goes from three thousand
to 9 500 in in two weeks and I'm like
wow if you put a sign on the front door
it really helps business because
remember the time we're doing three
thousand a pizza we're doing
uh eight thousand a week and 50 Cent
beers and we're doing a thousand a week
in pool tables so we're knocking down
the 140 Grand a year in 1984 selling 50
Cent beers and five dollar pizzas and 50
Cent game of pool so you know I'm a high
strong mammal
um and I'm excited about what we're
doing so I go down to the Domino's and
the manager at Domino's I said what do
you do in a week because we're doing six
thousand a week 6 500. and I just looked
the guy and I go I'm going to kick your
ass in the whole world I don't know why
I just thought if you can beat him in
Jeffersonville Indiana why can't you
beat him in the whole whole world I
thought like that and I think it was
that naivety that you know just we're
gonna win we're going to get this done
I don't know if you call confidence I
don't if you call it momentum but the
thought of losing just wasn't an option
it just didn't it wasn't like we weren't
going to make the broom closet work it
wasn't like we weren't going to make
Papa John's work it wasn't like we were
going to make mixed Lounge work it was
just we're going to make it work and we
did so when you said that to the person
at Domino's was that like the owner
maybe the franchisee or was that just
like the cashier that's just like I
think
I remember the guy was a manager of the
store it was a manager so you just
straight up as a 21 year old just like
Hey we're gonna kick your ass like oh
where did that confidence came from I
just believe that if you took care of
your people we've always had a good team
I mean and you made the best pizza
remember the first the broom closet
didn't have a sign on the front door I
just thought if you had the best pizza
you win I didn't understand marketing I
had no idea that you you know you
marketed hell the products you know so
we had two fundamental principles
um you know take care of our employees
our team
that's herb Keller at Southwest nuts
that book is employees first customer
second we've learned over the years that
guest experience cannot exceed the
employee experience so if you've got
employees that are miserable you're
going to have guests that are unhappy so
we knew all along that we had to take
care of our people last year I was there
in 1617 I think the bonuses for the
employees was over 30 35 million dollars
so the employees felt like it was their
company it was the best place to work in
Kentucky for five straight years and
they're making bonuses we promoted from
within so everybody's getting promoted
you know when you build
two 300 stores a year you have all kind
of opportunities for growth internally
so I don't know how many millionaires
there were at Papa John's but I'd say
it's thousands thousands of millions
thousands of millions well we started
the company with sixteen hundred dollars
and when I got out of it the market cap
was three four whatever 80 bucks a share
is it you know three three billion three
and a half billion and where did you get
the money to start up that business I
didn't have the money
um I went down to Tony Manley at Food
Equipment Supply and he loaned me the
1600 worth of used restaurant equipment
by this time with the bar I'd build a
good rapport a good reputation and good
credibility with Tony and he said well
just pay me when you can pay me so
obviously I must have thought it was
going to work too but before we go into
that we got to thank our sponsor
hellofresh because as I'm sure you guys
know time is money and I cannot stand
wasting my time going to the grocery
store buying ingredients waiting in line
driving back it's a waste of time well
today's sponsor hellofresh takes care of
all of your meal planning and delivers
pre-proportioned ingredients right to
your doorstep hellofresh is also more
than 25 cheaper than takeout and it
saves you time and money and grocery
shopping hellofresh even offers quick
and easy options for breakfast and
lunches too in just 15 minutes you'll
have a wholesome homemade meal ready to
enjoy and I also have to say I really
enjoy all the variety so my housemate's
a vegetarian and the recipe that we made
from hellofresh came with both a
meat-free option and a meat option so
everyone was happy and that was just one
of over 40 different meal options plus
if you need snacks or sides just head
over to hellofresh Market and take your
pick from over 100 add-on items so why
wait go to hellofresh.com and use the
code 50 ich at checkout to get free
shipping and 50 off that's
hellofresh.com code 50 ich to get free
shipping and 50 off or use the link Down
Below in the description to try it out
today and now with that said let's get
to the podcast what was it about pizza
for you that was so special because I've
never seen someone so passionate about
the product like that I'm still
passionate yeah
um we made pizzas when I was 15 at
Rocky's and I fell in love with pizza
and I drove a forklift at the day I also
welded barges during the day at Jeff
boat but um
made pieces of night of Rockies and a
case of beer
um for Miller Miller Lite cost us about
nine dollars and we were selling it for
9.40.
um Iraqis were some pizza for nine bucks
and the food cost was three dollars so I
knew early on that I wanted a higher
margin business than beer sales I wanted
pizza and I was washing dishes at
Rocky's and I hated wash the dishes and
so you weren't allowed to make pizzas
unless you were a fondrisi Joe John or
Frank fondrice so they got a good ride
up in the scene the thing took off and
sure enough I got promoted from washing
dishes to making pizzas and that's when
I knew that's what I wanted to do so how
did you as a dishwasher get promoted
when you had to be a fundraisy like did
you did you prove to them that like hey
guys I'm in this for the to win it
basically like I can make good pizzas
trust me yeah I was I was an exceptional
employee I was always nope I was just at
the right places
I'm just lucky change your last name to
fundraisy yeah yeah also when you were
running the the first ever pizza shop
out of the broom closet was that nine
thousand dollars a week that was Revenue
that was sales that was total sales yeah
I remember in the room closet in the bar
this is early on my brother and I on a
Tuesday night did 200 in sales and we
were jumping up and down we thought wow
we're rich 200 a day in a broom closet
we really thought we had that kind of
hey respect for a dollar
um for reality but we just thought my
gosh you know how can you ever spend 200
with no overhead so we were that was and
so we were doing three thousand a week
we thought we three thousand a week out
of our room about the size of this bar I
mean you're getting with it and then we
just moved it next door literally 40
feet and the sales went from three to
nine but what was the profit on that
nine thousand dollars a week that's
interesting too when we first started in
the bar
we were doing big burger and a beer for
a dollar
and we were destroying all the little
small Denny's and Jerry's and sandwich
shops around the bar so the owner
Jerry's comes over Charlie Warren says
you know what are you doing I said I'm
doing um first of all I said I can't
talk to you we're too busy I said come
back in an hour so he came back in an
hour and we just destroyed their lunch
business with a mcburger and a beer for
a dollar he said what are you doing and
you know said he goes what's your food
cost so what do you mean because the
college they don't teach you food costs
I had no idea what he was talking about
and we added it up we had a dollar 20 in
the pier in the mcburger because it was
a double burger it was double Patty
burger with you know extra cheese and
tomatoes so
um we had no idea that we were losing
money on every sale we just know we were
selling that
so by the first store our first employee
who's still with us today Denise
Robinson and her husband he was a driver
she was a bartender and she was also
really good with accounting so after
that lesson on mcburger we started
um doing analysis every week on What's
um what's the food cost what's the labor
cost and back in those days we were
running 40 38 to 42 percent food I mean
today you know A bad month it's 30
percent
so we didn't have the buying power we
didn't measure the cups we did a lot of
things wrong but we were still making
money because remember we built the
stores ourselves we were running them
ourselves we were free labor so we were
still making money but I'd say 9 000 a
week we're definitely making 10 15
percent where do you think you got your
work ethic from that was the beautiful
thing about growing up is my dad's side
um was Democrat extremely liberal
um and he had nine businesses and they
all failed the other side was the
Ackerson side which was very
conservative
and they saved their money very frugal
seven-day work 10 to the shop so it was
fascinating to watch one guy
really uh who was actually Dan was
probably the smartest one of all of us
he just wasn't principle oriented
with regards to work ethic
um you know handling the finances I mean
he had nine bankrupted businesses my
grandfather had three and all three were
successful so I was really blessed from
a political side to watch cause and
effect on a liberal Democratic
perspective
and watch the cause and effect on a
conservative perspective not only on
politics but in business and in life you
know I mean my Dad loved the racetrack
you know he loved to live for the moment
didn't mind running up the credit card
running up the debt kind of like what
we're doing today with our government
and you know and always he enjoyed life
he had a good time uh the problem is
there are consequences arithmetic is not
an opinion and I got to watch my
grandfather who was a multi-millionaire
by the time he died he was in the West
in Louisville but he um had a degree in
accounting and a law
and just his reputation his credibility
he thought we go everywhere we go to
um
the farm store we go to the the grain
store the seed store and he would always
say
um I said people you got money and he
said I don't need money my credit's good
and I never understood that you know I'm
six eight seven years old and
the later in life understood how
important it was my dad had bad credit
couldn't get a loan in the bank and my
grandfather my mom had impeccable now I
was at a slam on one or the other it
just I'm just telling you what happened
and I'm telling you the cause and effect
of that kind of um ideology
um and and outcomes on behavior
um your your personality is what you
think how you feel and how you act and
so that's your personality and so to
watch the two completely different
personalities and to be able to kind of
go back and forth I can remember
in college I was I didn't know who was
right no this is 80s this is Reagan and
of course Ball State was very liberal
college and I was torn well you know
this is Pebbles my mom in the action
side and college is kind of my dad's
side it was like you know I really
struggled
um in 8081 on which way is the best way
to go
and I can only imagine the kids in this
day and age where they're kind of asking
the same question and they're they're
getting indoctrinated with
um you know bad reality
um the greatest mechanism for poverty to
get rid of poverty is
um the Capital Market you know
entrepreneurship that's the greatest
invention of man is capitalism just is
and you know
um capitalism only works if
um you know the entrepreneur thrives now
Adam Smith called it the Invisible Hand
I disagree with Smith on this in the
sense that if you take an employee
that's going to wash the dish through
the night or clean the sidewalk off or
make the pizza okay they do a good job
or they do a not so good job versus the
owner does the same job he's got a
different mindset you know I mean that
dish is going to be spotless that pizza
is going to be a good pizza That
Sidewalk I mean owner when you know you
have property rights and it's your shop
you're going to have a whole different
perspective a whole different energy and
that's all entrepreneurship is that's
all labor workforce is energy you're
gonna hold have a whole different
magnitude of energy and labor that goes
into your skill That's Not Invisible
that's John Snyder saying I want out of
the bar I want out of the broom closet I
went out of Jeffersonville Indiana and I
want to live in the Garden of Eden if
there's nine businesses that failed
in hindsight from your perspective today
why do you think this failed is because
he overspent yeah is it bad management
yep again
um you know we'll take the frontier
Lounge which is actually 100 yards from
mixed Lounge Mr Riley's hamburger there
today but the frontier Lounge they
bought that
I think my grandfather loan the money
and the bank alone the money and you
know next day at lunch they go in he's
my dad don't always get he would say
give me a chocolate
on Wheels which is bourbon and Coke and
a styrofoam cup give me a chocolate on
Wheels so you go in take two 300 out of
the cash register get a chocolate go to
the racetrack and blow it I mean that's
just the way that was just how do you
think that's so different though from
your grandfather because it seems like
usually these things are are seen and
observed by you know the kids they see
the work ethic and why do you think he
was so much different you know I mean
first of all it's two sizes of the
family Ackerson so you know why are they
different I look at my grandparents on
my dad's side they were Irish in German
Schneider and a Patrick my mama and POI
who were my dad's parents were the most
frugal down door
I mean my grandfather
um you worked two jobs he was
um
electrician and then he would do night
work
my grandmother was a stay at home mother
that we had Sunday dinner with after
church every Sunday
Um how my dad came out of that
environment the way he was I I never
made sense of that
again he had a great life he only lived
to be 51.
but I mean he had more fun in 51 years
than the rest of us put together going
to have in 81 years I mean it's not it's
not a slam I mean
um it would cause an effect and it did a
lot of damage to the the family when he
didn't pay my grandfather back and he
would skip town on stuff but you know
when you you know it's your dad you love
your dad no matter what you kind of go
okay what can I take out of this that's
most beneficial and that was probably
just to enjoy life and you know to love
life and and to you know be thankful and
grateful for all the blessings and to be
in this country I think that's what my
dad you know did he another thing my dad
taught me was he's not he wasn't afraid
to fail you go where did that come from
I guess my old man I guess my dad I went
okay if he can behave like that and
still almost be successful because he
would you know he was making 100 Grand a
year in 1970 practicing some walls so he
knew he always made good money he just
couldn't handle it
um but
um you know I learned to take risk I
learned that you want to be in business
for yourself he had to learn that you
know you want to have a good time but
not at the expense of you know your
finances and your physical health it's
interesting how impartial you are about
the different takeaways that you got
from your father's way and your
grandfather's and your mother's side of
the family uh do you think the pros
about having an elevated sense of fun
and enjoyment on your dad's side and
this kind of Carefree nature was in a
sense a better way to live because you
said he loved all 51 years of his life
rather than potentially the the other
side which is a little bit more of a
scarcity mindset rather than a mindset
of abundance Living For The Moment has
consequences
and I think the greatest thing about our
country is you know life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness and and Liberty is
about freedoms the the word Liberty
comes from
the French where you know the government
leave me the hell alone you know right
now they want your stove dishwasher I
think now the washing machine's up I
mean they want to control everything
we're doing I mean that's the
anti-American you know so
I think each individual in this great
country has
the responsibility to be an independent
critical thinker
to um
show mutual respect you can't have
mutual respect if you don't have
self-respect can have self-respect if
you don't have personal integrity
so I think it's up to each person
to decide how they want to live their
life if you do something to hurt
yourself
um that's one thing
if you do things to hurt yourself and or
others that's a whole different mindset
so
um I think as far as living for the
moment and doing self
um you know self-destruction that's an
individual's decision you know because
there is there's consequences cause and
effect I think anything you do that
hurts other people that's why I'm so
down on this Administration is because
what they're doing to your your
demographics your age
um and what they're doing to the people
to wake up and make this country great
is just catastrophic the Border fentanyl
um the child trafficking the the sound
of Freedom that just came out we've been
studying that for over over a year year
and a half you've got
um 32 trillion in debt and you all
that's going to do is diminish you're
all's income the next 5 10 20 30 years
because when you run deficits you print
money and you print money it's a hidden
cruel hidden tax on the taxpayer in
future years so all these things with
regulation
um high taxes uh inflation leaving 80
billion dollars of equipment in
Afghanistan and letting 13 servicemen
get murdered
um uh you know just it goes on and on
and when you're hurting the very people
that you know the middle class is the
heart
beat in the backbone of this country
without a strong middle class you have a
two-tiered society and I don't like a
two-tiered society because you either
have rich or poor and sooner or later
the poor folks get tired of seeing how
the rich folks live and you have a
revolt revolt wouldn't be good at all
for a guy like me
when I was in Ireland we were going to
go to UK
we had a detour to Ireland because they
had an inch of snow you United Kingdom
handles stole like Atlanta Georgia so we
stopped in Ireland and
um I said we're going to get a hotel so
we found this Castle
to get this whole it would turn into a
hotel it was an old castle
it was hot I mean it was cool I mean
Bowling Alley Pub golf course it was
pretty cool for you know just last
minute so next day I'm checking out uh
look at the lady and she's part owner of
the business I said this is pretty cool
how come there aren't more castles
turned into hotels
and she said well
um because
the owner was a good landlord I said
what do you mean he goes well he made
sure that the farmers The Peasant
farmers and the people that worked had
profit share and he took care of her
and I said really and they what'd they
do with the other castles say well the
landlord screwed The Peasants screwed
the farmer screwed the people that do
the heavy lifting
and they burned them down and so back to
people and product at Papa John's if you
don't take care of the people doing the
heavy lifting you don't take care of the
people really doing the work they're
going to burn your Castle down and
that's where we're at in the country
um and I think when you get away from
the framers
ideology and principles I mean out of
the say the 45 or 50.
um
uh founders of our constitution 37 were
Merchants we're businessmen and women so
I mean they understood free markets they
understood human nature they understood
Common Sense human nature both good and
bad
um and as a result our country is being
able to thrive for 230 years but I do
think we're pushing our luck a little
bit here again again arithmetic's not an
opinion we're spending money today
that's going to cost you guys and your
kids down the road and just you know I
don't say that to be slamming but I mean
to think math is an opinion and don't
think there's a cause and effect on you
know 16 inflation in two years that's
called a compound and that you you know
you spend 32 trillion and you know just
did the kova thing I think they're
missing a trillion dollars or 600
billion I mean yeah I mean 600 billion
is over 600 knees
yeah
I mean gone out you know throw it out
just burn it that's just one aspect of
it so um but the framers did a fantastic
job
um they knew
a cast of characters like we have today
where's just one lie after another from
these politicians I mean they're all the
Deep swamp you know both sides are
guilty but they knew that with watching
all the kings dictators and throughout
history they knew that that in politics
stinkers rise to the top
and how they figured out a system to
keep the checks and balances I mean
they're almost now the point where
they've got to throw away the decision
on the Supreme Court I mean they've
actually got to disregard the
constitution in totality
um to get their way but how the framers
put in the checks and balances to kind
of keep this thing
together is pretty amazing I mean
everybody thinks we're in a democracy
we're not a democracy democracy we're in
a constitutional republic you get
elected through voting then you make it
old to the Constitution
and I'll give you an exhibit a of how
corrupt it is it's very clear in the
Constitution that Congress controls the
first strings
the Congress controls the money
and yet
we have a president that just wanted to
give away 500 billion dollars whether
it's good cause or bad calls I don't
want to debate that but he wanted us a
serpent
Congress there's nine people in the
Supreme Court
plain as day
Congress controls the purse drinks
president overrides it three Supreme
Court Justices who swore to the
Constitution
swore to it
it's in plain writing violated the
Constitution that's the story here you
got three justices that are supposed to
be made an oath it's supposed to be
constitutional lawyers in yet defied
reality that's crazy when you first
started Papa John's how did you ensure
that you treated your employees fairly
correctly and where did you learn how to
do that if you're not honest then you're
playing games You're vulnerable I don't
want to be vulnerable you know I don't
mind making mistakes make a mistake you
take the hit you own it can move on
being honest is in is a selfish act I
think it's in my best interest to be
honest
I don't want to be vulnerable because
you can say well you said this and you
know he he said this this one I don't I
don't want to be I don't want to be
caught in that situation because even if
you're trying to play it totally
straight and totally clean you're still
going to have things that are you know
opaque or nebulous that you've gotta
either reconcile or take the hit or you
know substantiate but what happens when
you don't treat a good employee good
we go somewhere else and so it's again
it's in my best interest
to make sure we take care of the good
employees and then try to get the
employees that are not so good up to you
know higher level of functioning and
performance who's the first person you
hired Denise Robinson seven bucks a day
two bucks two two bucks an hour for
three and a half hours and what was she
doing for you she was she was waitress
bartender dishwasher and accountant
she's still with me today no way yeah
how did you first meet her well this is
back to my dad yeah um we'll go for this
almost Go full circle in one story we
take over we're doing a couple Grand a
week then we start the mcburger thing
and then we're doing the plate lunches
and all of a sudden we're doing five six
a week headed to seven or eight pool
tables we're doing 200 a week and now
they're doing a thousand
and I'm like this is on the roll so we
need help so
um my dad interviews Denise Robertson
um and um he hires her and
um nieces you know she's attractive
she's fit
hard worker
um
you know great disposition
um great composure I said that's great
he said there's only one problem
and I said what's that I called him
champ
he goes she can't cook
well
you know I'm like you heard a Coke that
can't cook you think somebody are you
crazy I said and I was hot I was like
yeah
I'm trying to get yours out of
bankruptcy we don't have the seven bucks
and you hire a cook who's never cooked
he goes I want to train her
I said that's that's that's BS I don't
you know he goes she's got a great
attitude
and plus she's got a nice ass
and I went
you did what you hired a cook that can
cook because she's got a nice butt and a
great attitude
and she worked out to be the best
employee of all of them and so I think
the lesson from dad there was you know
higher for attitude trained for aptitude
but you know he just was able to he
would do things like that the myological
mind would say you can't hire a cook
because I didn't know how to cook you
know anything but Pizza
but he um he made the best hour of any
hire we've ever had as far as we got her
husband too her husband was a delivery
driver for us forever as far as cooking
the pizza how did you come up with the
perfect recipe and how did you
understand what the customer would want
okay Rockies we cooked out of a obligate
of it
it's kind of a cheap machine it's kind
of it's 10 and you know the deck on it's
about this thick and then at Greeks
Pizzeria we cooked out of Baker Pride
601 which is a you know it's a 1200
pound oven it's the deck on it's this
thick takes forever to get hot but I
mean it's a real machine and then like
gaddy's was cooking out of uh in in
penders Lincoln impingers
they were conveyorum and they weren't
too good so I learned on early on that a
oven is has to be the piece of equipment
you get right and so I mean those those
deck ovens were over 2 000 pounds but I
didn't like the Bellagio cook at Rocky's
it it didn't have enough horsepower that
when you got busy you put the pizza in
there and uh it wouldn't get cooked a
Baker's Pride you never ran out of
horsepower and then we switched to
middleby Marshall compare Ovens that was
pretty suspended because in the early
days you get the burn out of you
because you know you're just busy going
over pizzas the pizza in the back would
always cook bashing the pizza in the
front
because it was in the back it's hotter
so the boxes were never in the right
order a conveyor oven first pizza ends
the first pizza out so that was a really
big deal and that would have been 87.88
when George Marshall from middleby came
in and said listen I'll I'll put a it'll
be Marshall oven in your store and you
don't have to pay me for it until you
decide you want it I'm like this is like
thirteen thousand dollar twelve thousand
dollar oven that's if it's free I'll try
it and we used to do a thousand dollars
in a deck oven and you couldn't wait to
drink a six pack of beer and you could
do a thousand dollars an hour in the
middle being not even sweat it really
was quite the um quite the advancement
in Innovation and efficiency and just
not getting burnt all the time but then
what about picking ingredients and the
cheeses and the the Breads and the
pepperonis
how did you decide what the right ratio
was and how to perfect that most people
have rocks for taste buds
so they just want something cheap and
filling
um so I think half the half the
population has a good taster on them so
I feel like both sides of the family
were pretty uh discreet when it came to
food quality and taste
the first thing we did is we do we like
it did I like it you know something I
could be proud of and without exception
ingredients
um
the better ingredients that taste better
always cost more money
the only thing slightly different than
that is cheese we'll talk about cheese
here in a second but that's the only
ingredient that whether it's an olive
um
or sausage
pizza sauce flour I mean you get what
you pay for and
the farmer friend out in Modesto packs
my sauce used to tell the snappy dog
food story The the CEO chairman of the
board of Snappy got in front of all the
employees who's the best who's the best
snappy snappy snappy snappy dog food
who's number one snappy snappy snappy
who's got the best quality Snappy dog
food everybody's going nuts and he looks
at the audience and says how come our
sales are down 20 percent
and a new employee stands out the back
and says because the dogs won't eat it
and the the point of that story is
you know
you know do they come back do consumers
come back you know did the dogs eat it
so how did you go from scaling outside
of that broom closet into your first
chain or franchise into the next one and
the next one because that sounds
incredibly challenging especially for
someone that's in their early 20s to be
able to do something like that yeah
we'll start it
um 40 000 feet a macro and then move
down to store one I thought
the bigger you got the easier would get
5000 was harder than four four was
harder than three and three was harder
than two and two is harder than one
thousand I didn't I thought once you're
paying people a million bucks a year
some cases two million a year
um Co the last year I was there made six
million and you're paying people that
kind of money it should get easier and
it just didn't
but by far
the first
two or three are the hardest store two
was five times harder than store one
in store three was ten times harder than
store one and two
in store 10 was twice as easy as three
it got easier at ten but that's the only
point where it really got a little bit
easier because we could finally put in
some kind of hierarchy some kind of
administrative support so we weren't
doing everything do you ever felt that
people took you less seriously because
of your age being young and how did you
overcome that I still have that problem
today
[Laughter]
um
that was the blessing yeah because pizza
domino should never let me get the
two-store to store two thousand they
they laughed at us they poke fun on at
us they you know ridiculed us
um but they once we got to 2000 we could
do National advertising and so we had
them but they should have never let me
get past 300 stores and they could have
stopped that now what are some of the
things your competition would do to slow
you down I've heard so many stories
about like yeah our competition would
would do this and they tried to undercut
us here and like have you ever dealt
with something like that well yeah I
mean once they realized it was too late
and
97 98 they sued me take down better
ingredients better Pizza that went all
the way than the Supreme Court so yeah I
mean they had lawyers they tried to
steal all our people they do three
dollar pizzas we'd open a store and
they'd give pizza away I mean yeah they
do everything possibly imagine but it
was too late because we were over we
were already past two thousand we we had
momentum what was the what was the claim
that they that they sit against better
pizzas better ingredients was that just
like you can't say that because that
implies that our ingredients are
inferior and they tried to sue for that
um well we were we were poking them
pretty bad at the time it's not so much
today but the time we did we did use
better ingredients and fresh pack sauce
and less water in the cheese and higher
protein in the flour Hard gluten content
we we had all we we were walking and
talking better ingredients the problem
is is that's subjective in other words
you can't prove that a
um uh peach pie in the frozen section of
the grocery is not as good as the
grandmother makes in other words it's
Common Sense the grandmother makes a
better peach cobbler than a frozen peach
cobbler in a supermarket but you can't
you can't prove that so better
ingredients better Pizza why in my mind
we paid more better for you it was more
authentic I ate not a bunch of additives
chemicals and there's no common sense
says well it is better but legally it's
a subjective question so that was how
they they you know hung their head on
that and they won in Texas but that's
where pizza was located they won in
Texas and we were going to take it down
and we appealed to the fifth circuit
they said this is crazy you can you know
everybody says better and everybody you
know makes a claim
and we won that Pizza Hut appealed and
it went to the Supreme Court the Supreme
Court held up the decision the fifth
circuit otherwise we would have taken
that slogan down and when you were
scaling from that first broom closet
into the next 10 were you taking any
profit for yourself or were you
reinvesting all of the revenue generated
from these businesses to just continue
scaling well when I first started at the
bar Labor Day weekend of 83 I was paying
they paid me 200 bucks a week that was
my pay and I remember going into 84 and
I had like
20 checks you know
um I had well you got September October
November December so you got 16 to 20
checks 18 checks that could other words
I couldn't cash the checks because we
were overdrawn we always made decent
money but we didn't make
we didn't really start making money
until
1990 but I was still spending it faster
than we could make it and we finally got
a loan for a million dollars alone and
they finally loaned it and then we went
through the million dollars so quick
because I was buying ovens I was
building stores awnings mixers in 92 I
got turned down for three million
and I always wondered where the
threshold was how can I make more money
than I'm spending I never you know I
thought it would be store 50 store 100
and then we went public June of 93 with
232 stores
and we were getting close but even at
232 I still could spend more money
building stores and growing the stores
we had that we were making
we went public and raised 25 million
dollars and That Was Then the need of
capital once we went public we no longer
needed Capital so why why did you decide
to continue reinvesting in building more
stores rather than taking some problems
well I lost my I lost the partnership on
that
87-88 I had two partners that said we're
making at the time making 700 000 a year
and we're 200 000 overdrawn
so they didn't like that program they
actually thought I was probably taking
money which you know was not the case if
they didn't understand the difference
between a p l
and cash flow you could have a positive
p l but if you you know if you're buying
equipment you know you're putting out
capital for you know signs and awnings
and ovens and building stores you can
you can go through that so they didn't
understand that so that was the then
that partnership but you wanted to
continue reinvesting and growing the
business you didn't care necessarily
about getting some money at the end of
the month to go spend on certain things
that never crossed my mind that was a
that was a point of contention
you know we had to write a pretty good
size check back in the late 80s
um
but that was a that was a good divorce
uh in the sense that when you have two
different mindsets we just talked about
that with entrepreneurship at the top of
the administration if you don't if
you're not really pro-entrepreneur
pro-small business they're going to feel
that
um if you have one
group of partners that don't want to
grow don't want to be on their boats and
drive fancy cars another another one of
them guy that wants to live in you know
the basement of the house and pour all
the money back in So someday he doesn't
have to work I think those two mindsets
are both justifiable not one's right or
wrong it's just this you're probably not
going to get 5 000 stores and this you
are but this this is going to take a lot
longer and be a lot more painful so I
think it was a good it was a good
divorce did it make you nervous though
seeing your father and your grandfather
and not feel like I should take some of
it off the table well I can't at least
secure my future now and then reinvest
afterwards no and until 93 where
um we went public and remember in 92 I
couldn't get three million dollars
to build the company
and then all of a sudden in one day the
company's worth over 150 million dollars
so as soon as we went public you know I
own 90 of the company so I went where I
didn't have five grand to go on vacation
or buy a new you know I drove pickup
trucks so we didn't we didn't have fancy
cars we didn't you know we didn't have
you know nice homes at the time
to Rich beyond my expectations and when
Adam's 31 by the way they don't have
books out there when you make 100
million dollars out of a broom closet
when you're 31 years old so you're
saying you didn't have five thousand
dollars to go on vacation wow as soon as
you went public you got a hundred
million dollars overnight effectively
the company was worth over 150 million
which I owned like 80 90 I owned 88
before we went public I think um
I'm gonna say 78 but pick a number you
go 70. it's going to be more than 70.
and so anything change in your mindset
where you're like okay I couldn't go on
vacation now I'm extremely wealthy like
not even wealthy but like ultra wealthy
it didn't hit me how much money that was
until I retired
um back in 1718 2000 I didn't realize
it's one thing to create
um
your net worth of let's you know 500 or
800 or a billion let's just pick a
number of 200 million it's a safe number
it's one thing to build your net worth
to 200 million it's another to have 200
million in the bank and not and know how
to invest it if you know if I was the
most important word in the English
language is focus
um and so the next thing I do
um I'll be a hundred percent behind that
I just haven't decided what I wanted to
do yet because it doesn't meet my four
criteria which we'll talk about if you
all like but um the
it it's taken me probably three years I
think I haven't made any mistakes with
Investments
um
and that's a key you know compounded uh
annual interest is Einstein said it's
the most powerful thing in the universe
so we haven't had any years where we had
some flat years you know but it's it's
okay to be flat you just don't be a
negative 10 or 15. those are the years
it's called a volatility tax we live
that in 2000 where the market was 29.6
let's say 30 and it went down to 196
let's say 20. 30 to 20 is a third
but to go with 20 back to 30 is 50.
so you get forever third you lose you
gotta have 50. so that's what you have
to avoid those so we haven't had any
negative years
um and we've been real solid with our
oil stocks and our gold and our dividend
stocks
um but to understand the game of Wall
Street I mean two months ago 95 of the
people out there saying we're going in a
recession
Market's gone now what 31 to 35 and I
mean 34 and a half 35 I mean maybe 35
and a half anyway they don't know
they're crazy I mean you know short term
is Buffett says it's a uh a voting
machine long-term stock market is a
weighing machine so sooner or later the
arithmetic the objective will come into
play but I mean Wall Street they're nuts
I've seen it I've seen Papa John's stock
at 90 but I'm like should be 75 and I've
seen it at 35 and it should be 60. I
mean they never get it right and so you
have to know that you're never gonna out
maneuver out think somebody that's
irrational
short term the long term you can play
them like fools how do you not get
complacent like 1993 comes around you go
public 150 million dollar valuation on
that business how do you still keep your
foot on the gas and be just as motivated
I've got 10 of the best therapists in
the world and they they can't figure out
how to get rid of that
um no that's I mean that's the problem
is learning how not to work
that that was you know when you're going
from 5 000 stores 120
000 employees to zero in one day that
was a real shock
you know so
um but I think you you know the
spiritual work I've done
um and the advice I've gotten is from a
lot of smart people and myself is be
patient but opportunistic four criteria
it's got to be authentic you all see I
like real I like stuff that's real you
know it's truthful authentic genuine I
like that two is it's got a better
Humanity pizza was fine but it does it's
got an obesity issue that bothers me
it's processed food that always bothered
me so whatever I do next I don't want to
be selling tobacco or own the bar or you
know something that's not healthy for
Humanity I want something that benefits
Humanity I.E Papa Farm I'm playing with
that three is it has to be sustainable I
don't want to be feeding this thing
every month I mean I don't want to have
to put in you know 100 Grand or a
million dollars a month to keep it alive
and Fours has to be scalable I like big
stuff so I haven't met or found anything
that meets those four criterias of yet
does it need to be profitable and making
money
it you need to make money because
when you do things the level I do it you
have to reinvest
um
know we just went over that exercise
we're making 700 Grand a year and
spending a million you know because you
know when you when you when you do
something uh that's authentic and high
quality it always takes more time and
costs more money and so if you're not
making a profit you're not going to be
able to execute the level that would
that would satisfy me on my personal
standards so you still at this point
continue to care about Building Wealth
increasing your own personal I would say
well I'd say most people make hundreds
of millions of dollars to make hundreds
of millions more I made hundreds of
millions of dollars so I can enjoy my
life now the caveat there is there's no
reason to do something stupid I mean you
know I mean there's no reason to tickle
the tail and
um I mean I I I've got a deal a day that
comes over my desk because everybody
needs Capital but as soon as I invest in
something it's going to take my time you
know let's say we do something with a a
organic small retreat
the CEO is going to call me well the
maintenance guy quit or the pipes in the
building burst I don't want to hear that
unless I'm doing it unless I'm running
the show you know now if if I'm running
the show and I've got you know a way to
go in and and really expand it and grow
it big then I don't mind the pipes
bursting and people quitting but
um until I find that thing I want to
focus on I don't want to be bothered
with I mean you know my concept of a
perfect day is I don't want any phone
calls and no meetings how you all got
this done I don't know but you know good
for you guys but for convincing I think
that's it we're persuasive I wonder I
feel like what could be interesting for
you would be something in media because
it seems like you you're highly
opinionated you have certain things that
you value right near and dear to your
heart and you want something where I
feel like you could potentially push
that ideology make it a large change and
that's very scalable it's highly
scalable highly lucrative and also it
does change the world to something that
you could view as better right and there
are other media companies that already
exist that maybe could be bought out
that mirror some of your opinions well
Serato didn't tell me you guys were
looking for Capital
[Laughter]
oh if you get if you got an idea on that
media I'm not sure I think you'd be
fantastic you're you're fantastic on
camera you're well spoken uh I don't see
it I don't I don't see that I see it
okay and you have TV you're articulate
which I mean we've done so many so many
podcasts and some people they have they
struggle to get their words out in a
very constant ways of way in a cohesive
way and you do it very well no you're
kind of I don't I don't see that when I
look at the interview I don't first of
all usually don't look at the interviews
and second when I do Adam I mean I don't
get upset with myself but I don't think
okay that was really good you know I've
heard you say in some interviews that
you were always worried about going
broke I'm curious where that came from
and at what point did that stop yeah
that was that was a real
um I think that was a real limitation in
my character
um the
we we grew up and again my dad made he
was making 100 Grand a year in 72 and
they'd always they he wouldn't pay the
bills they turn off our water turn off
our electricity the look on my mom's
face when they you know would try to
repossess the car or we were a year
behind exactly a year behind on our
house payments and the water would be
turned off
and I remember a lady across the street
Phyllis Huber her husband was John Hill
and Budget rental cars in Louisville she
would cat around in a Mercedes Blue
Mercedes convertible Benz and my mom was
gonna lose you know had a boat beat up
Monte Carlo and was you know going to
lose the car and I could just remember
when they would turn off the water and
the gas my mom was just humiliated and I
mean
I don't remember the exact conversations
but paying the bills was like a big deal
to my mom and she hardwired me that if
you don't you know Papa was all about
credit you know your word your Bob and
mom was
if you don't pay your bills on time then
you know you're you're worthless and
that was a little bit overkill on that
and so
we're cruising through the 90s worth
hundreds of millions of dollars
everything's going well and I'm still
worried about being broke I'm literally
thinking that you know and I guess you
if you do enough drugs and I guess
enough divorces and I guess enough
gambling I guess you can go through you
know hundreds of millions of dollars you
really got to work at it but I was
worried and um
by this time you know we're at store
turn of the century we're over 2 000
stores and you know you just got to grow
um with your your management style your
your competencies and your presence so
we we started hiring coaches and you
know most the coaches
um they weren't they weren't all that
smart you know and so they really
weren't helpful but I did bump into one
guy he was really smart
um and um
he looked me over and up and down
he said you know pizza boy you got a
problem so what's the problem he goes
hey Vietnam
what do you mean he goes it's not your
house
it's not the bar it's not the broom
closet they're not going to turn your
water off they're not going to turn
electricity off your mom's not gonna
go to bed crying because the bills
aren't paid Vietnam's over you made it
stop it I said what do you mean
Vietnam's over it's over
we're here today and it stuck and that
was the end of you know that fear
that was 99. one of the greatest gifts
that I ever got was a guy going you know
it's not Vietnam you know it's not the
it's not the bankrupt bar it's not
the sweaty broom closet with no air
conditioning it's not how do you feel
like that held you back because I very
much operate from the fact that like
every day I'm like something's gonna go
wrong prepare for like going broke and
I'd like prepare for the worst in
everything is like my Baseline and a lot
of people said well that's a scarcity
mindset you shouldn't be doing that you
should operate from abundance but I'm
like well you know you never know how
old are you uh 33. well I mean give
yourself a break when I was 33 I
couldn't carry your luggage
um it's 60 you take the position the
universe is always working for you the
universe is never working against you
you just don't realize it and so once
you learn to fall in love with the
unknown
you know unlimited possibilities
unlimited opportunities
unlimited success infinite opportunities
once you realize the universe is always
working for you never against you
um then you kind of get rid of that a
little bit but I think
the byproduct of being too much on the
broke side or there's something going to
go wrong
is you know attitudes and emotions are
infectious they're contagious so if
you're worried about not paying the
bills or you're worried about something
going wrong which I think is a terrible
mindset I'm not being critical of you
I'm just you know I think to be you
cover the downside the upside takes care
of itself I get that you know I have a
helicopter you don't want to go to a
helicopter with one pilot and one engine
and one Hydraulics and one avionics that
Kobe Bryant had no egg Onyx no terrain
avionics on that Chopper and it was a
shikorsky which is a 11 million dollar
helicopter and One Pilot eight
passengers One Pilot I mean you know you
just you got to have redundancy so
um I think you you but you can't look at
it what's going to go wrong because
you'll go through people and I was in
the mid 90s I was going through people
too many people that's your barometers
are you losing good people and when
you're losing good people then you got
to take a hard look in the mirror and I
think it's a constant you know the
difference between wisdom and sin is the
ability to self-confront you know so
whenever I have a problem like let's say
we have a little disagreement on what
we're doing here I'm always going to go
in and go well okay what did I do to
make that problem you know I go inward
first okay
oh my God I did say I paid for the plane
ticket oh
we did talk I did tell you two hours or
the other way is no you told me you
needed two hours and now you want five
so you know I mean you go in first and
then you if you're not the problem you
know and you know in your heart to heart
if you're the problem you're the
instigator or at least part of the
problem and then you go outward next but
the difference between sin and wisdom is
ability to go Inward and self-confront
I'm curious because it seems like you've
had so many aha moments in your life
from what you've heard from that coach
to that moment when you did 9 000 a week
and then you realize that the local
dominoes was doing six thousand a week
what's different about those specific
moments to give you that Epiphany from
all of these other moments that happen
in your life that don't have that same
level of change within you okay you
don't get rich
by cash in the check
you don't you don't get it's in a
one-step process
you get yourself in position
to get yourself in position
[Music]
to cash the check to get rich so
everything success is nothing but
discard the bad and you keep the good
easy said sometimes you know hard to do
you gotta have the discipline
we always understood that the grand
victory was not a one day or one year
process
the the grand Victory is baby step wins
every day maybe step wins every week
every month every year on the way to the
Grand Victory sooner or later people are
going to look up and say wow they got a
thousand stores or three thousand or
five thousand it's like somebody that
lays bricks we're gonna go out and watch
these guys leave bricks here because
they're 70 years old
they get off doing this labor at seven
years old I mean they're strong as an ox
and then they go walk five miles and you
know all they care about is church
laying brick they're family and fishing
you know and they're 70 and they'll
probably live to be 100 you know but
when you look at a building that's a
hundred stories in the brick on the
outside it was one brick at a time and
all of a sudden you look up one day and
there's 100 story building not a brick
and so if you do the baby steps it's a
brick one day at a time and you keep
having these little baby wins every week
and sooner or later you're going to have
a grand victory
so those little uh best of Louisville
you know hiring you know a great CFO a
great is person being first on the
internet these are all little baby wins
that we try to do and accumulate every
day to eventually have you know 5 000
stores and celebrate the grand Victory
how did your philosophies change over
time going from essentially a startup
uh to a large business owner and your
roles throughout the entire process did
you just learn as you went along and how
did your day-to-day activities change we
always believe from my mom and my
grandfather's side that in integrity
based
model
of discipline accountability
uh frugality
taking care of people collaborative we
always had that on a three-dimensional
um
world of Newtonian physics
the product well we paid people
service cleanliness of the store the
look of the store
on the Integrity based cause and effect
we had that figured out
we didn't have the terminology for it
back in 1985 but the principles the
ideology were were set from the get-go
the quantum field the physics of
manifestation and synchroniticity we
didn't we didn't really understand that
until the last four or five years
that you know that uh
that the the molecule in the particle
are controlled by the field energy and
frequency and vibration control you know
the particle the molecule the atom we
didn't understand that
um uh we we we pretty well lived in the
Newtonian
uh realm a Newtonian World we're good at
it look around you know you want
somebody to move particles and move
molecules you're talking to the right
guy
um and you know if you want to build a
railroad across the country you got to
sling a hammer and nail nails but there
is an easier way to go through life and
I think the problems were
having today especially with our
politics in the division of this country
is not going to be solved in the
Newtonian level it's too much too much
fighting too much quid pro quo too much
disregard the hatred the anger they have
I think it's going to take a spiritual
Realm
and uh of goodness kindness and
compassion to fix the problems we have
and we always had mutual respect and
kindness and compassion but I don't
think we understood it in the realm of
frequency and vibration
and Source you know I mean what's 90
99.9 of everything out here is dark
matter we don't even see the energy I'm
talking about yet you know when you look
at universes expanding infinitely
infinite times per second
you realize the amount of energy and
vibration that's out there and the key
is how do you tap into that through the
quantum field yeah and we found Joe
dispenza being is probably the best
we've seen at tapping into the quantum
field through the penal gland
to get divine inspiration he thinks the
pineal gland is the antenna to the
divine and the Divine has all the wisdom
all the knowledge all the equilibrium
all the
Brilliance that we need we just got to
tap into it have you always had those
beliefs or was there a moment that kind
of clicked for you where it's like you
know I can control my own reality
whatever I believe will eventually come
to fruition Newtonian physics is my game
it's all analytics it's all arithmetic
it's all mass and inertia and momentum
I mean geometry I mean that's you know
that's my world I mean you know that's
where I excel the quantum field where
you you have the intent and you have the
emotion come back of what it feels like
when now that
um
that's that's the last five years four
years but I think we all thirst for
something greater than ourselves
I mean what are we here
why are we here and what's our purpose
and if you you break it down to where
things need Tony in
materialistic then you know really I
mean there's nothing higher than that
there's nothing more important than that
there's nothing more sacred than that so
now the the quantum where you you move
particles and molecules and matter with
energy versus moving molecule and
particles uh and matter with molecules
and particles that matter that's just
coming into fruition the quantum work
the quantum field work and a lot of
scientists are working on this and it's
it's really coming into play quite quite
nicely the way it hangs together even
though I can tell you if you put out the
intent
and you and you do get in the right
state where you're out in the
three-dimensional world into the quantum
field of nobody no thing nowhere
um it does work every time
um
I still don't believe it though
as I sit there well you know this is
what you do this is Einstein's physics
it makes total sense from a scientific
perspective and it works it's very
pragmatic and that's what I always look
at is the work
but you're going to tell me that I'm
going to cook to my penal gland put an
antenna out feel like I would have comes
back into a state of nobody nowhere
nothing darkness and it's going to
happen I'd say you're out of your mind
but I've never had it not work
ever yeah and by the way the the the
closer your desires are
your intent
to the current reality the faster they
they happen I can I can put an intent
out that I want to be worth three
billion dollars
but that's a that's a stretch right now
you know it just it's farther from the
three-dimensional reality
that the easy stuff you know that's
that's already right here excuse me is
going to happen much quicker with that
intent but to defend his work is it's
crazy I spent time with Joe
um he's a wonderful human being smart as
hell and he's unique he's a doctor
chiropractor
she got that aspect of it he's uh
Triathlon he's an incredible athlete he
had a really bad crash car ran over him
on his bike so I had to deal with that
on the you know some of the spinal
column issues and health issues he's
also an artist but his kids are
unbelievable artist so he's an artist so
you got this unique guy like Einstein
was scientific analytical but he said
the imagination is more important than
intelligence so Einstein was kind of an
artist too and you know the way he had
to think about you know speed of light
Etc and Jonah Spencer but Joe dispenses
work
is definitely going to change the world
if we could just be more of us like you
know getting that Quantum field of of
bliss and love and compassion and
kindness
and generosity and graciousness and
thankfulness we'd solve a lot of our
world's problems pretty quickly we got
to try to get Joe on because I got a
cool message to share I'm really
interested about raising children with
this level of wealth do you find it
challenging to instill the correct
values in them maybe as a parent
probably should with their with their
kids about not feeling entitled having
to work hard the true value of a dollar
how are you able to do this with your
children is it impossible to do at this
level of wealth that's a great question
and a it's got an answer that's not
exactly flattering but
um the
I dated my girlfriend in high school for
nine years we had a child together she
actually lives across the street she
lives basically on the property she's an
attorney your child or your girlfriend
from that long no myself
I was okay yeah I was okay
no it's my daughter it's my daughter my
daughter and my grandson live across the
street okay and she's interning and um
she's self-made and you know I help her
out here and there was stuff but she's
pretty pretty independent and then I was
married for 32 years and we had two
children and
um I was extremely attentive to the kids
and they lived uh an unbelievable
lifestyle
um and she was a great mom but the one
thing we did fight over is she she
pampered the kids it's it's a problem
when it comes to work ethic when you
know I mean when I'm six years old I've
got to get up and go work on my
grandfather's property
you know and you know my my kids are 14
and they can play computer games all
night and I get out of bed that that's
that's created some problems that way
um but you know all three are good kids
I've got a
friend in the real estate business
that's quite wealthy and he just had a
son
and he's adamant that his son's not
going to grow up like the other kids
were their spoiled rotten
but
um you know this this Millennial
situation it's one of the reasons I
haven't jumped back into anything yet
in the Gen Z is they
um they want higher paying jobs
more flexibility with ours more time off
they the worst tippers so they're not
generous
they don't feel like they have to show
up or show up on time
I don't understand how that works where
you you know you don't show up or you
don't show up on time you don't have any
problem not showing up you want a cushy
job with less hours with more benefits
uh by the way you're not generous I
don't see how that Arrangement works
with marriage or works with kids or
works with an employer
I mean when you your personal Integrity
is on the line when you take a job and
you say I'll show up that's your
personal integrity and when you don't
show up okay you hurt Starbucks you hurt
the company well yeah well you hurt the
manager well yeah I kind of did because
we heard the system area well she got to
come in and pull my shift well the other
employees have to work harder because I
didn't show up I mean that's enough
damage there with your self-respect
look at what you did to yourself you
know you said you'd show up said you
show up on time and do the job
and you don't I mean how can you feel
good about yourself so this is going to
be interesting how we've gotten away
from
you know a lot of the values you know
and now number one thing's money used to
be religion and faith and values were 45
now I think that's 18. it needs to be
money was 18 and now it's 45 so this is
going to be interesting how this the
Millennials and the the Gen Z's handle a
mindset of I really don't want to work
work's kind of something I really don't
want to do I really don't want to show
up when I do work and make money I'm I'm
not a very good Tipper that doesn't work
good of course I'm in the service
business so I think I'm big on tipping
so um you know
um but back to my kids I mean they're
honest for the most part they're hard
working and and you know my son's 25 you
know my two daughters are in the mid uh
mid-30s so
um they're they're good let's see what
they do with their lives how did having
kids change their philosophies on life
and business I think having kids you get
excited about coming home
um but as much as I love the kids
um what I really likes the grandkids
that's what I like here because
um um in both my oldest grandson Grayson
and my youngest uh grandchild
um John Buck whatever it is they both
have it
you know and you know it is when you
meet somebody and they've either got it
or they don't and they walk in and and
they just take over the room you know
they're they're and they're just happy
so I think that's uh
um I think the family aspect of it I
mean the other day if you don't have
support from friends and family I mean
I've got so many people that I'm
associated with that come from good
families and it's it's just a real asset
and then I you know I've Got Friends
that come from you know Obama deed
dead I'm willing to do with them and I
mean it's it's hard on the kids it's
hard on them and that my heart goes out
to that you know when they don't have
that family unit to fall back on I think
it's a tremendous asset to have and I
it's not an icy it's a necessity to have
you know I mean we all have good days
and bad days it's nice to have that
support system in place and I think that
starts with friends and family how are
you able to find the silver lining and
everything it seems like through all the
trials and tribulations that you've been
through you're still able to find the
good in it and then use that to your
advantage time and time and time again
did you learn to teach yourself that did
you have to learn how to find the silver
lining in order to be to to be fine to
be positive still or is it an innate
thing some inherent quality you've had
you know when they were trying to come
up with the airplane around the world
it's like six guys came up with airplane
all the same time on all different
different places in the world you know
that's just one example this happens all
the time
and so there seems to be a higher
intelligence the feel the energy where
there's you know something more going on
that we really understand
um but I look at it from a pragmatic
perspective
and you know my three-dimensional
world's pretty sweet frankly you know
I'm healthy my kids my friends everybody
nobody around us right now is having
health issues and you know that's what
you know as you get older that's
something you got to really look out for
but the key is you got to stay grateful
and stay humble I mean you know he you
know we just really are not that smart I
mean if you really look at the source
the Creator
um you know what you know the one
sentence that you just asked me the
question
4 billion neurons fired their
subconscious picked up 2 000 of those
and your conscious picked up three I
mean what's going on I mean there's
enough electricity going through your
body right now to go around the earth
ten times I mean it's just it's the the
intelligence of the Creator is so
brilliant
you know what's faster than speed of
light
well whatever created the speed of light
and how fast speed of light 186 000
miles a second
second I'm playing those 500 miles an
hour the thing I mean the intelligence
of this the source
um is just it's just so magnificent and
Brilliant that we're never going to
understand it but we can certainly
appreciate it and and understand
that we don't have the ability to really
understand you know I used to have a
saying to Papa John's this is the
johnism people that don't know they
don't know well they don't know and
um I just think that to think you know
it all or think you've got to figure it
out I think that's the beginning of the
end so if you just start with the
premise of I'm thankful for this day I'm
thankful for my health
I'm thankful for this three-dimensional
world I'm thankful for the ability to go
into a five-dimensional world and try to
figure things out at a higher level
and I think if you just stay really
grateful and and gracious and humble I
think that's 95 of it you read a lot do
you read Eckhart Tolle I've never heard
of that Eckhart Tolle it sounds very
similar to what you're saying to
something I've I've read in that what's
it about uh he's got I mean he talks
about the ego a lot so like your
identity your vision of who you are and
then I'll also also a lot about presence
and not being too concerned about the
past or about the future and stuff like
that so yeah beautiful yeah the um the
precious present moment is hard yeah you
don't want to live in the past because
you look at the past like my dad learn
from it you know you know it's great but
you don't harm on not paying bills right
you pay the bills
um in the future you can get too tied up
with that too but you know that's that's
where the quantum is is because the
present and the past and the future are
all here now exactly it's a it's a mind
you know the the the Creator The Source
just slowed the speed of light down slow
enough that we could have a
three-dimensional World hey if you
really look at quantum physics there's
no separation there's really no you or
no me it's us everybody which is a mind
screw in itself I got one last question
for you if we got to wrap up
um when did you decide to make your face
the brand of Papa John's and do you feel
like that was in that positive and in
what way that happened we had done some
commercials from 2000 to 07 oh
and I was in a soon time and nobody
really believed that was Papa John they
thought I was an actor and Jordan
Zimmerman came up with Papa's in the
house in 0809 and I remember in the
conference room and uh headquarters I
said oh you know
um I'm not too sure about this he said
you think it'll sell a lot of pizza and
I said oh it'll sell a lot of pizza
um but I said once you're in the
spotlight
and you have conservative values
um even if you're not political about
them
um which I wasn't at the time you know
but we ran the company on conservative
values in my opinion that's all we had
the success we had
um I knew that I was going to become a
Target
or the left so
um
we
we took the stock from
October
of 08 was 680 a share then when I got
off the bus in 16 it was 88 bucks a
share
so 12 12 fold so it was it was a good
run it worked out and both things
happened
um we sold a hell of a lot of pizza and
then you know as you know I got
crucified for something I really didn't
say but another problem with that is the
timing
if that would have happened today with
all the knowledge the consumer now has
about woke and cancel culture and they
had a tape of what I said
um it wouldn't have been wouldn't have
been a big deal you know been like hey
you know could have said it differently
but the intent uh and the position of
you know something that was anti-racist
not a racist slur was plain as day from
the get-go we just couldn't get the word
out because you know the time Twitter's
was paying
set the computer up for clicks so you
had 600 million Clicks in eight minutes
we don't even know how many of those are
really real people or how many of those
were manufactured by Twitter just to
hammer me because you know through a
fundraiser for a few Republicans so yeah
but it's been wonderful having you guys
thank you very much for having us
letting us into your home beautiful here
gorgeous and uh yeah we really
appreciate it who's going to run the
camera as we go around the grounds
that's Jack I got it yeah
cool awesome thank you for tuning in how
much time do you need until next time uh
to walk around there